As much as I hate to say it,
we are not done talking
about Big Publishing.
They're the ones responsible
for getting second graders
hooked on Popper-fueled
bestiality orgies.
Shame on you,
Mr. Popper's Penguins.
Now, the bookistas have aimed
their sharpest pencils
at one of our great
conservative thought warriors,
former Breitbart senior editor,
Milo Yiannopoulos.
Now, if you don't know Milo,
you clearly haven't been living
under the correct rock.
(laughter)
He's the alt-right's
premier agent provocateur,
who effortlessly
triggers liberals
with un-PC comments like these.
I know what you're thinking.
"I gotta hear more
from that guy."
And bigwig publisher
Simon & Schuster agreed,
giving Milo
a six-figure book deal
shortly after Trump was elected.
Now, a few months later,
those literary cuck-teases
killed Milo's book deal.
Why? Left-wing media bias.
Take a look.
Yeah. Milo is the same
as Amy and Lena.
Between the three of them,
they have an Emmy,
a Golden Globe
and a lifetime Twitter ban
for racistly trolling
Leslie Jones.
Exactly the same.
But Milo will not be silenced.
Like the free-speech
crusader he is,
Milo is suing
those book-loving bastards
for $10 million.
But here's what just dropped.
Simon & Schuster's
public court filings,
which include Milo's
original manuscript
with the editor's notes.
Last week those notes hit
the Internet, and they are...
mildly unflattering.
(laughter)
But now, snowflakes and SJ-dubs
are having a field day
on social media,
celebrating like Whole Foods
is having a clearance sale
on matcha tea.
Here to talk more about Milo's
persecution by the left
are citizen journalists
Josh Sharp and Aaron Jackson.
-Thank you, guys. Thank you
for coming. -Thank you.
-Thank you.
-Thank you, Jordan.
-(cheering-, applause) -The libs
are soaking their panties
over this editor's shady notes,
but the truth is,
giving Milo an editor
in the first place was fascist.
Yeah. He's a freethinker.
He shouldn't be bound
to totalitarian publishing ideas
like common decency
or basic book structure.
Yeah. Aaron and I have
never used an editor.
We just quickly write down
what we want to say,
feed it into the teleprompter,
and then say back
whatever is ribbon on here.
Yeah. That's what FreeSpeak
is all a-pouch.
Heh. I puddin'
agree moron, guys.
Yeah. And while the soy boys
on social media
are going gaga
with this editor's "takedown,"
the truth is that a lot of
these notes are pretty standard
in the mainstream
publishing industry.
So let's go through some
of these notes
-Milo got from his editor.
-Yeah.
(both clearing throats)
Okay, here's the first one.
-Hmm.
-That's a totally standard note.
The editor on Little Women
said the same thing.
The character of Beth
was originally in blackface
-for the whole book.
-Yeah.
Or how about, uh, this note.
Okay, everybody gets this one.
It was one of the early notes
on Animal Farm.
It's actually why Orwell decided
to make them animals.
-Mm-hmm. -The first draft was
just about Nazis on a farm,
-and it was called Nazi Farm.
-Yeah.
Some more editorial feedback
Milo got when he wrote
about Pizza-Gate.
(laughter)
You know who got this note
all the time?
Dr. Seuss.
(laughter)
Here's an early
Cat in the Hat draft.
(laughter)
-I love that.
-Mm-hmm.
-And it's great for kids.
-Yeah.
Okay, now,
Milo got lots more notes,
but, again,
they're all standard.
-Stuff like...
-Standard note.
Standard note.
A classic.
-Hello! That is so (bleep)
standard. -Yeah.
I know I ask you guys this
all the time,
but when is the time and place
for a black dick joke?
Now that the book is canceled,
we'll never know.
Oh, God. Injustice, right?
I can't believe they pulled this
book just because
he made some pithy observations
about women,
Muslims, trans people,
black people,
fat people, gay people,
people with disab...
Oh, no, no, no. Jordan, no.
The book got pulled
because Milo made some rather
provocative comments
-about pedophilia.
-Yeah.
All that hate speechy stuff
is the reason
he got the book deal
in the first place.
Yeah. So you can cool it with
your woke Twitter parades
about the Simon & Schuster
clapback, libs,
because these notes
were not written
-by some heroic social justice
warrior. -No.
They were written by a
professional editor
who was part of a team willing
to pay Milo gobs of money
for his ideas,
so that Simon & Schuster
would make gobs and gobs of
money off of Milo's ideas.
Gobs and gobs, Jordan.
All right, Jordan,
we have to go.
We're off to read the racy
unedited version
-of Hop On Pop to some kids.
-Yeah.
And, yes, Jordan,
it's about exactly
-what you think it is.
-Uh-huh.